so today I wanted to talk a little bit
about a story so and this story started
two years ago and I had a friend the
close friends we were both in London and
this frenzy runs a small investment fund
and and he was moving to New Zealand
okay and then usually when you move to a
new country well you have family in
other countries you might need to move
some of your money from where you are
right now to somewhere else right and
while doing so and you might expense you
know different things such as you know
the exchange rate they need to find a
reliable service and has to be quick and
the government doesn't have to ask
questions and so on so forth okay but
there is something strange I was talking
to my friend at any basically said have
you ever noticed that there is something
something going on with these services
okay there is something weird so you
said go to have transferwise are you
familiar with transferwise most of you
are so if you're not familiar with
transferwise it's just a way to transfer
money from one currency to the other so
in this particular case I've got the
transferwise website and what we're
looking at is the two currencies we've
got euros and we've got British pounds
and what we interested in though is not
just the two currency but the exchange
rate so in this particular case my
friend said have a look at the exchange
rate and jot down the the value okay the
number let you see in this Patil case
we're looking at 88 cents as an exchange
rate from Euro to pass and then said go
back just refresh the page and and start
from scratch but this time just swap the
two currencies right so we go we used to
go from euros to British pounds we go to
British pounds to euros and he said
again do the same thing just look at the
exchange rate and write that down okay
and so I did that I'm just looking
exchanged write that down and these are
the two exchanges for the two pairs of
currencies that we are interested in and
they decide
imagine you're sending money to your mum
okay let's imagine you're sending
thousand pounds to your mum right we've
got British pounds and we send we send
euros
so for each British pound then we're
gonna go at one point fourteen something
something euros so at the end of what we
get
let aren't okay okay what if we send the
money back now just you know we change
our mind we convert all the euros we've
got back to British pound well easy
enough we can do that we've got the
exchange rate that we saved and run and
we just do the multiplication and this
is what we get oh oh where are these
three cents coming from looks the
interesting okay surely right is gonna
be like some sort of bugs we
transferwise Shirley's you know
something that they do wrong probably
not so disease I don't know if you're
familiar with these artists up is called
a revolute again based in London and it
was similar things and they only be more
than just transferring money between
currencies they're also sort of a bank
they are applying for a license so it's
very exciting space but we're not
interested about anything more than
exchanging rave so if you'd look at the
numbers here and you look at exchange
rate so we've got 88 it's in the middle
it's quite small about 88 cents and 1.13
on the other side so this we can do the
same sort of map that we've done earlier
on right and if we do if we buy these
thousand 136 pounds and twelve pence and
we convert them back at 88 cents or 0-2
this is what we get back I've got a cent
okay but why I mean that I'm creating
mining out of nothing like where's the
catch to explain how it works and let's
take a step back right let's imagine
that instead of going to transferwise or
it revel it you just go to your bank and
you say i want to transfer some money
and there are two cases you are in the
same country so you're in singapore and
you want to transfer money in singapore
then you don't incur any transaction at
least i think i don't incur in any
transaction I hope I don't but anyway
you don't encourage they definitely know
in England and you get the money but if
you do if you transfer the money with
your bank from your account to someone
else account which is not in the same
country then what happens is the bank is
gonna take hey you have the fee from
from the money you're transferring okay
so that's a little bit of a problem
and then companies such as transfer wise
and redwood came up with a really really
interesting solution and this is how it
works instead of like having like just
two people want you to exchange money
they actually had that pair of people
wanting to exchange money you can see
that the person at the top would want to
transfer a thousand pounds the person at
the bottom won't transfer 1200 euros
which are similar right so the clever
people that transfer wise said what if I
convince the guy at the top to give to
give the money to the guy at the bottom
and I take the money at the bottom from
the right side and give it to the first
one if I do that right we never ever
move the money outside of the country we
are just the middleman that moves
inviting from one side to the other okay
so and that's exactly what they did
right they basically find a really
clever way to transfer the money inside
the same country instead of moving that
money outside of the country now to do
that of course they charge a small fee
but it's in comparison to what a banker
charge
that's just like tiny no this is what
works for the pounds and this is what
works for the euros you can see that
Eddie and
I get the same result and this is great
but it is not great when I start having
a lot of different currencies right I
need to find more people wanted to do
this match right in this particular case
we had in the previous case we had euros
and in British pounds but as soon as we
had one more currency into the mix then
we need double the people to just match
everyone else demand ok so that's why
services such as transfer wise and
revolute they offer you really really
good deal when you join because they
need to have a unit a massive user base
to be able to transfer this money around
which also takes us to liquidity so
market like transfer wise and regulars
they are most of the time just not very
liquid which basically means that
sometimes your money can wait a little
bit longer to be transferred on the
other side because we need for someone
else in that country to move the same
amount of money out of the country at
that point we can do the match and then
we can do the transfer so all of this
will say ok oh good we know how to make
3 pence maybe more hun I mean it's it's
it's more than nothing but it was still
like it's tiny what can you do with it
it turns out that not all the platform
works in the same way so what I was
looking for platforms that do transfer
money between different different
countries I came across this other
website called currency fair and then as
was interest in exploring this space I
built a small dashboard in d3 and that
Bass Pro basically would track the
exchange rate for each pair it will tell
me what happens the interest of fingered
by currency fare you can see currency
fair here is that had a really really
good sort of exchange rate which
basically meant that if I were to
multiply and this assumed that I could
transfer a thousand pounds worth of
money from British bands to urine from
euros British bands back I will get four
pounds
great so if I have to transaction per
day 20 days in a month this is the best
side project I had in a in a in a while
right the first side project who
actually makes money it was it was like
a dream come true right so and that's
what I did I said okay I I can build
this stuff okay
it shouldn't take long so I'm gonna
build it so when I started had three
sort of goals I want it's a side
projects right so usually the girls are
I want to play with toys I want to play
a lot of toys and need to be shiny so I
had three wishes when I started and the
wishes were well the first wish was I I
definitely need something that can
listen to changes right the thing is I
showed you the happy path when things go
okay and the two exchange rates are
actually good and you make money but
sometimes that actually not making money
at all now if I have two orders and the
exchange rate is not profitable I want
to cancel my order and I wasn't gonna
lose money so I want my my tools I want
my system to be reactive to changes
right I want to listen to price changes
I want to say listen to all the changes
so if an order is matched or partially
match I want to notification from there
and I also want to know if there is any
money coming in when it's coming in if
it is going out so I can basically
decide if that I should place an order
or not right so this is the kind of
events I was looking I was looking into
and the other interesting things I
wanted to play with was a time traveling
I know who wouldn't want to play with
time traveling right I mean it's not
that kind of time traveling where you go
back to the future but it's the kind of
time traveling that we do all days if
you're using react and redux okay so
this is simple to do up and all we're
doing is adding and removing items
through from a to-do list but if you use
Redux and real and Redux tools you can
basically replay the session as you know
is easy happen so you can basically go
back in time and why would you do that
well I thought if I
could record all the actions coming into
my system so price changes order coming
in
Orlin being matched then I could
actually replay them and just make sure
that my algorithm is doing the right
thing
so doing time traveling would be quite
interesting to explore a new possibility
for my algorithm and also to inspect
what's really going on the third sort of
goals I had was to make sure that my
system is Beliebers so this is my son
maybe you know crazy but not crazy but
just weird but at the time when I was
working on it then this news came out or
someone accidentally publishing some
test data on NASDAQ
you know in New York they're on NASDAQ
exchange and taking down the entire
store for Amazon and I mean I'm not
making things up you can read you can
read the press release and someone
basically just you know miss type and
and publish the test data and that
crashed the stock I don't want that to
happen to my but I'd rather not lose the
money if I can and on a similar subject
I also tried the same Eiger in there on
the stock market and you can see this
stock is quite expensive he's a hundred
thousand dollars pair stock and one day
I'd was testing stuff and and for some
reason well I forgot a break close in my
look and he just kept you know buying
everything but I was like if there was
an added bug that actually prevented the
order to be submitted so the double bag
saved me but I learned a lesson that
time I said was better better be safe
oops so I is what I built at the first
MVP I had was basically a combination of
a small message broker like octave and Q
and then I had a database where I could
save all the prices and the orders and
this is what it looked like so you can
see I had like in my no gesture
plication which was in charge of making
the decisions and then the ruble and Q
is basically just a place where I could
place the messages and consume them and
then you'll see as a worker that could
just basically consume and publish
messages into the queue
and and it was great and it works so I
could basically grab information price
information from the exchanges and
ingest them in my application and then
save them back to the database it was
great until it wasn't it was a leaving
over-engineered so it took me like ages
to get it right running but I think the
most big problem that he had was
actually the state and now I'm gonna
explain why because this is perhaps
something a little bit more interesting
than the me over-engineering a side
project but um we have currency fare on
one side and your application on the
other and then usually what happens is
all the orders right are storing in
currency fare so the the exchange and
then what you would do with the
application you would say hey please
send me the order I'm gonna store them
locally okay that's what you do and then
you say I want to know the price so I
can make a decision if I should place an
order or not and then you get an order
back you get a price back but you know
if in that timeframe one of the order
changes there is nothing notifying you
because you're not subscribing to it at
least
I couldn't subscribe to the exchange for
in this example the order to you goes
completed so it's not available anymore
now I just I just show you that I
received the price information I
ingested that price information and
actually what I realized is that I'm
losing money so what I want to do is to
update the order but if I update the
order the API is gonna say well that
order is gone
game over okay so that was a real
problem for me so I I basically decided
to scratch all of that and then go back
and think about a better way to do it
and a better way to do it for me what at
the time was and had a look at these new
programming language I don't know if you
heard of hum but I think the easiest way
to think about it is just look at Redux
I always basically
a much better version of it and then the
way it works is very very simple all of
your state is in one single place if you
want to change the state you need to
send a message and what happens is you
have a function that takes the zoo and
gives back a state so this is what it
looks like this could be a message right
so just a plain object and in the state
it's just basically again a plain object
so what you would do you basically take
a function that takes the message in the
state crunch them together and returns
the state okay that's what all Redux is
and I thought well this is great right I
can have all of my states all of my
prices all of my orders inside the state
and I can be clever about it and just
you know this time maybe keep it simple
just getting running first and I did and
it was kind of great
he had redox so you had a level DPS or
an embedded database
you know package it is this is docker
container as well I was really excited
about it
I had one challenge though and then if
you're using Redux you probably find
this every day when you when you're
building an application with Redux so it
is this way to send a message in the
state then usually what happens is
you've been told by every guide on the
internet every sort of tutorial or a
material you read is that you cannot
have side effects since I already
realized I'm a state and side effects
I'd like HTTP calls or doing a console
log or the set interval and usually what
you should do is you should refactor
your code in such a way that sign of
facts are outside of your story and
that's usually what's recommended so if
you use redux in the past you probably
familiar with these actions and then
basically here what we're doing is just
refactoring this action in making sure
that they are outside of the state and
then what we end up with is just another
type or event and then we create a state
with the extra events and suddenly we
refactor all the state and and it's pure
and everyone is happy and in fury a
story on the internet you can take all
the boxes or good the challenge with
that is that your state and your flow
separated and with that I mean you need
to do something on one side in the
action and then you need to go on the
other side and making sure that it's
actually in sync with everything else
which I Foley just madness and there are
a bunch of project actually trying to to
address that so you might heard of Redux
saga relax sank my back
mob X is doing something similar but I
thought it was like really something
that I couldn't live with I want to have
my actions next to my state I don't want
the two things to be separated so I went
on an improve cyclisation trade
sufficient free has a slightly modified
Redux version and what he what he had
basically I have the same state the same
message and instead of returning just a
state
I will return a state and a series of
commands you could think of the commands
would like to side effects I will pass
to someone else and this is what it
looked like
Oh basically you I used to have the
update order inside the action now its
incited inside my state and what it will
happen is well basically the update
order would basically just be a
description of what it would look like
what the action looks like and this is
what happens so I I send a message to
the update I get back here stays in the
command a series of commands and these
commands are just description of what I
want the action to be and then I will
use something like an interpreter so
just like a JavaScript object that takes
commands and then executes strength and
there could be like an HTTP core I
console.log acetamide also all the
things that are impure that produce side
effects will be encapsulated in my
interpreter so that's interpretive
pattern and this is what I looked like
right I would return a fetch and that is
just like a description of what I want
to do and then I would have an
interpreter they will go for each
command and actually execute that action
so no side effects it was good I thought
everybody was really clever because of
lack of play with toys but the reason
why I thought it was really good is
because I can make a request and I can
say I want to fetch an order and it goes
efficient order but because it's an
interpreter right
could change the execution of
interpreter without actually changed at
the logic of my application and I could
implement things such as WebSockets
without anyone noticing it because it
was inside interpreter and not inside
the application itself so if Allah
allowed me to do things such as that or
even better I could basically change the
interpreter all together and just use
mocked version of my services so that
was quite quite a coup if you're
interested in the kind of space I would
suggest you look at sort of these three
tools and but at the end of the day was
quite interesting so I haven't stayed in
logic together I loved that it was very
very easy to test and interpret I could
just mock things out so it was really
good but it was Ali be complicated I
went down really hard path doing
something weird so I basically decided
to quickly to refactor that so in the
end I settled on this this design which
was basically actors so instead of
sending something special I would
basically have like messages going
around and being posted on small queues
inside the application and then going
back that's basically what what it is so
it ended up you know I started with a
really on very engineered system with
queues in my sequel I ended up with a
really really small to application and
that was just two hundred lines occurred
for the the framework to send messages
and making sure that I could react to
them now before I jump into into some
results I'll just quickly mentioned what
I found really really interesting so the
testing side I think what I found really
interesting is that you want to test I
show you why you want to test you don't
really want to spend millions on on the
stock market just because of a back but
um one of the things I noticed is that I
will find myself writing this code which
is testing something where and then I
would you know come up we saw we've with
test cases and then I will come up with
test negative test cases and then it
would look like this which is really
really long when in reality what I was
doing I was just changing the values
inside this this object right
the function that the bottom was the
same I would just just tweak those two
numbers so I found this really
interesting library which already
recommend and which I'm not I'm not able
to pronounce but it's basically just a
way to refactor your test in such a way
that they are data-driven so in this
particular case you see the effect the
function I want to update is at the top
and then I'm just using I'm just
changing the values in the given and
they're allowing me to basically write
way more tests oh and then I usually do
and and that brought up the confidence
level I have a power ahead about in my
application the other one good one and I
think this is just the right general
recommendation I think typescript is is
really really good and the reason why I
find it good is because most of the
times you have things like this right
you have an order and you start
developing your application and then you
know most of the time you realize that
you forgot and you need an extra flag
like active for example is the order
active or not then you add the extra
plug-in if you don't have typescript
then you need to go back and retrofit
that flag to every other object you've
got in your codebase now if you're doing
a small project that's probably doable
but if you have like a legacy code base
that's not doable at all things like tie
straight in difficulties just fro an
error and help you refactor that object
so you have the confidence that
everything is the same across the board
the last one is about integration so we
talked about unit tests I think I'd
really like this gift when it comes to
integration test and unit tests okay so
if you have a lot of unit tests it
doesn't mean that this is gonna work and
it was the very same thing for me as
well but usually end-to-end test
integration tests are quite hard to
maintain right but the interesting thing
was because I went down the well because
I went down the rabbit hole and ended up
with a different version of read a so
one of the things I could do was to
basically record the market as a series
of event and then replay them and making
sure that the result of my code would be
the same now I know this is probably
very very small but this is like a
Bitcoin market
and I'm just recording the sessions
we've order can be seen prices coming in
all that come is it coming in and out
and then you can see that they're always
written down as events so I recorded a
session and now I can just replay the
session whenever I want and just make
sure that they the result of the state
is the same as I progressing through my
test or my development but I know you
what you're all waiting for right did it
work was all this testing worth it yeah
really optimist well it did work you can
see so this is the graph showing the
number of orders I would do during a day
so you can see that some days I was
really lucky so that peak that had up
there is about 24 order 24 order placed
in a day and you can see other days I
will basically be a little bit unlucky
could be because it was testing or the
market wasn't particularly good and this
is over 3 3 3 months and then you can
see this is the revenue and that I had
during during 3 months and it's kind of
going up so I think it's a side project
is was ok for me can you guess why that
happened crash anyone else back actually
that was my wife she realized that he
was working so she gave me more money
okay so in the end I made like twice the
investment which was really good I
thought I mean it's not a lot of money
but you know playing with this kind of
toys I wouldn't expect any any sort of
money whatsoever actually worked and I
made almost a thousand transactions when
I got this email and let me let me email
because I think when I read the email I
was pretty sad I hope you hope this
finds you well
no it didn't find me well we are just
completely some routine checks on your
account and wanted to contact you regard
your how account has been used mm-hmm it
would see your predominantly using it as
a trading platform maybe so currency
play wasn't happy that I was making a
lot of transactions on on their platform
because this is against their Terms of
Service
lesson learned lessons learned so read
the terms and condition of the services
that you using it was my lesson lesson
learned but I think I want to focus on a
couple of occur on a couple of things
here and the first one is it it's a
trading bot in JavaScript only five
years ago I was playing with script
kiddies on jQuery on a browser and now
I'm doing an algo trading bot with
nodejs I think the jas community is gone
a long way from being just you know a
couple of guys coloring stuff on on a
browser to being you know a fully
program like three fully you know
grown-up programming language that can
do a lot of stuff so I'm really excited
about things such such as types craved
I'm really excited by things such as
Babel shows transpilers Redux which is
introducing back in back and sort of
paradigms law such as secure or ass to
the front end I mean we don't even know
this stuff when we're using it it's so
powerful so I'm really excited about it
the other things I'm really excited
about is actually trade when I started I
didn't know anything about trading I I
didn't know how it worked and I spent a
lot of time just understanding
and one of the things I was looking at
it's just you know you go online
everyone is saying oh why using javac
trading you should using C++ or Python
or it's something else so you should
have an MBA or you shouldn't need these
special hardware it needs to be really
fast this just doesn't work that way
just just a bunch of [ __ ] really
well what really made it made the
difference for me is that training at
the end of the day it's just basically
calling api's you can do it with
JavaScript you can do it with vash you
can do with any technology that can call
API so the that doesn't need to be any
sort of special skill it's not something
that's relegated to people who has
studied finance you can do it I think
that was the big message for me and then
the other one was yes are being caught
by currency fare but but what what if I
replay the same stuff on another markets
is the big bitcoin Marcus suffering from
the same sort of inefficiencies can i
play on two different exchanges and move
the money are there actually stocks that
behave in the same way is the forex
market money plated and in times of the
day or here where I could actually pray
my either it so if you're interested in
this token this kind of stuff so for me
was a big big lessons in in side-effects
and how to test things properly but if
you're interested in the kind of stuff I
think I'm gonna post the slides you can
you can visit all of these links and
they contain more informations about
about sort of building this sort of side
effects free applications that was
everything I wanted to show you today
[Applause]